we're talking about Dustin Johnson
winning the US Open but for some reason
with technology all the technology we
have the USGA screwed this up royally
when you you go from the fifth hole
where you see something you have a rules
official on on-site who says play on the
12th hole you tell Justin Johnson were
reviewing that and then Joe Buck doesn't
know how many Dustin Johnson's won by
because they still haven't made a ruling
yeah it's absolutely mind-bending and
these are the people who make the rules
for the game and that there's you know
it turns into a committee decision
there's a rules official with the group
who makes the ruling to start off with
end of story
yeah that's it you know that's the way
golf works apparently not you know
there's a you know it's the old story of
you know if you got a committee
designing a horse you're gonna get a
camel but I'll tell you one of the great
performances when you put it into
context you know this is Dustin Johnson
someone who had won swiped out from
underneath him at Whistling Straits with
another very dubious ruling and has had
so many near misses and is you know
people have so many doubts about him you
know for him to come through and win it
by three or four or whatever it was with
with with all of that stuff hanging over
him on the back nine is just a fantastic
performance but David how concerned are
you with technology in golf where it's
good for the amateur but we're seeing
what the pros do and with the golf ball
or is it the clubs they're hitting at
350 yards yes yes Golf meant to be
played at 350 and can you see a time
when golf maybe Augusta says we're gonna
have our own golf ball that you must use
our golf ball when you play in this
event now we have wearing degrees of
golf balls but it's gonna be our golf
ball that's gonna present prevent you
from you know the Bombers here yeah well
Jack Nicklaus who might consider to be
an expert said you know 30 or 40 years
ago the hey the golf balls getting too
quick need to do something to slow at
time but again you know the people that
make the
rules for the game maybe they didn't
consider Jack Nicholas to be an expert
you know they just let it get out of
control and for years now I've been
saying the one simple fix for this we
when I grew up playing at one point six
two inch in diameter golf ball the
British standard and then in the early
seventies and want to say we all
switched to the one six eight the
American ball they need to make the ball
bigger again make it one seven two
bigger surface area it doesn't go as far
spends a little more so it's a little
harder to control we just make the game
that little bit more difficult and it
would bring all the old hazards and our
old golf courses back into play and
these kids could use whatever equipment
they wanted you know and I don't know if
if you make it a professional ball you
know that would make sense to me but
having said that the amateurs would want
to play it because you know they want to
play the tiger tees you know go back and
yeah but it would just bring you a mean
that there's far too much real estate
being used in golf courses and and all
the examiners they want to play the back
tees and the game takes 6 hours and it's
all counterproductive but we've Tiger
proved they Jack proved to gust uh you
know there's certain times that I think
people thought oh there tiger proofing
because you know of what he's doing but
are we gonna get to Bubba and Dustin
Johnson proofing well here's the thing
Jason Day you don't see this in any
other sport you know in tennis or in I
mean you're swimming for instance you
know it's coming up in the Olympics well
they're swimming too fast
let's put jell-o in the pool I'm trying
to slow them down when does it become an
insult you know is it an insult to the
golf course or is it a compliment to the
player well we also lose Golden State
that maybe the 3-point shots too easy
and I'm thinking they're doing it better
than anybody who's ever done it now we
want to punish them because they've
seceded from everybody else and do this
it's evolution is what it is it's the
evolution of our species we need to
[ __ ] it in some way you know hold it
back is the the Tiger mystery here where
it just feels like there's a mystery
that the yet you still want to maintain
the tiger mystique it's good for
business
oh yeah but the
that he's not playing how long can you
continue the Tiger mystique or this
cloak of veil of secrecy with Tigers
future yeah I spent a little time with
him a couple of months ago down in
Houston opening a new golf course is the
first one he's done in America bluejack
national and you know I I have the sense
that he's been really careful with this
one because perhaps he thinks it's his
last chance you know to get this right
and it's a nerve issue it's not skeletal
or muscular it's just one of those and
you know what it's like when you start
having work done in your back and then
it has to be redone no boy I mean that's
a slippery slope at times Odia prevented
this yeah you know I'm not sure I'm not
sure the thing about you know Tiger at
his peak was if you if you remember say
the next best player in the world say it
was Ernie else you know when I else hit
the ball as hard as he could he looked
slightly less likely to fall asleep on
the follow-through there wasn't that
much difference yeah you know when Tiger
hit the ball as hard as he could there
was a you mean you thought oh my god you
know he must have torn his sack you know
or something you know I mean it there
was a visceral kind of a Oh what was
that
so I think it was those swings maybe
that might have done the damage you know
there was such a violence to them you
know so could he have prevented it maybe
but you know we wouldn't have seen the
you know some of the extraordinary
things that we saw can he come back and
play at a level that he's comfortable
with our expectation level is gonna be
hired way too high but can he have an
expectation level where he says I'm okay
with this I'm not the best player I can
compete I might be a top 50 player top
40 or 30 I think he would probably have
to feel that he was better than that but
I don't think that his expectations for
himself are you know I can get back to
the way I played from 97 through 2007
something like that I mean my children
won't see that kind of golf and their
children might not see it it was the
most extraordinary thing but I mean he
proved you know winning in US Opens by
15 and the Masters by 12 and British
almonds by 10 and that he didn't have to
play as best to win and as good as these
kids are now
you know Jordan and Jason you know
Dustin Johnson and Ricky Fowler and Rory
McIlroy they're not Tiger Woods they're
they're not you know in that particular
category he you know is a species of one
if I said pick out somebody who might
threaten Jack Nicklaus is all-time
record I can't think of anyone
none of these younger guys well because
it's too too hard to win majors these
days as so many people can win them the
strength and depth there's so much you
know it's so much deeper than it was
that the thought of winning eight of
thought of winning 14
it just seems out of reach really you
know if you can win seven or eight maybe
get to tan would be an extraordinary
career these days so Jack's record safe
I think so yeah because I don't see
Tiger I don't I don't think he could he
could play consistent golf for four
rounds at a high level at forty years of
age you know to ask him to win five more
you know if he comes but if he gets fit
and you know he may not be able to get
fit you know you know it might not we
may not be able to see him play again I
don't know what he play on the Senior
Tour the champions to I doubt that very
much I think you probably buy one of the
Bahamas certainly what I would do the
open is coming up it's not the British
Open it's the Open Championship yeah
we'd like to go we'd like to take this
show they're not this year mm-hmm but
you know I've just curious what you
thought if we went we took the show
there we would dress appropriately we
would act appropriately yeah which is
inappropriate I'm a killer yes I would
wear a kilt yes but what do you think of
us and being unleashed
I think I'm great it's it's such a great
event it's huge and it feels you know
Open Championship golf courses are such
wide open expanses and and you get them
the canyon at rune it's magnificent you
know the club houses at the end and the
massive stands with the big yellow
scoreboards above them when you walk
into that on Sunday it's a it's a really
special feeling that can't be duplicated
anywhere else in golf and the
tended village is a different sort of a
feel of two you know you you you smell
the sea air there's a I don't know the
gulls Sun differently there they they
hover to watch the Gulf everybody the
whole time if you could have one that or
the Masters oh that the Open champion
what it means to your country yeah yeah
I mean I had a couple of sort of brief
looks that maybe trying to you know for
that Turnberry and six that royal trim
but there was always one one place in
the back man where if I've made at this
putt I would have had a genuine chance
always missed that putt and looking back
at it it was I didn't want the
responsibility that came with it wasn't
the fear of failure it was the fear of
success you know on what comes with it
Oh mmm that's heavy
yeah no I'm around a lot I think that's
what holds most people back from there
there's a comfort and mediocrity
you know I'm nothing you can be mediocre
and play golf for twenty years and make
a living but relatively speaking you
know if you stick your head up above the
rest you know that's that's the
dangerous place and I think most people
don't really want that feeling you know
jack and and tiger and and jordan spieth
they love being in in the heat well
David Duval didn't know he did you like
it
no didn't like it once you know he kind
of accidentally won that yeah and and
you know didn't like it afterwards hated
the spotlight everything that went with
it it's always great to see you too good
luck i I will see at the Olympics you
can see the Open Championship on NBC and
of course
David's talk show Feherty is back last
90 at Rory McIlroy and he'll be on
Fallon in July he'll be at the Olympics
coming up in August I leave out anything
oh I don't know I I I'm going to the
Olympics to give things viruses I have
not heard of the ferdi controversy yet
but are there shots for that I'm not
sure no not sure I think it's incurable
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you